Okay. I got a voicemail that actually it's
a, it's sort of a, I don't know if it's a
troll or someone just trying to instigate,
but they actually bring up something really
important that I've discussed before. So let's
take a listen to it. I'll remind you, our
voicemail number is two one nine two David
p. If you reminders with peace and love, if
you leave a three minute voicemail and get
cut off and call back because you had something
that was longer than three minutes and you
have to finish it, the voicemail is not getting
played. We've never played these three minute
voicemails on the show, so keep them pithy,
keep them short, get right to the point. Let's
take a listen to this one that came in overnight.
Hey David, I was curious how you and a other
self-described progressive ponding on youtube
are content with profiting off.
Well, first of all, the word is pundit, not
pundant, but go ahead.
Right. When controversy while simultaneously
the crying, the far right, for example, you,
Sam, Sita, [inaudible], the young terrorists
et Cetera, are arguably their biggest platform.
For example, you felt compelled to appear
on Jesse Lee Peterson show not only once but
twice cause somehow appearing on a racial
sell of podcast is going to help the civil
discourse in America. Then you also interviewed
Richard Spencer, a literal Nazi, had advantage
of Parallon and most recently Sam Harris,
who's a race realist and is on record saying
people just don't know how to get arrested,
quote unquote and respond to racial profiling
in the u s how is this not more counterproductive
than beneficial to the free market place of
ideas and civil discourse in America?
Yeah, so listen there, there's a bunch of
different issues here that, that we need to
discuss. First of all, this idea of profit
you're against right wing ideas, but you profit
by criticizing them that I did. I just don't
even understand that argument. It's like,
oh, you're an environmental cleanup company.
Advocating for corporations to be more careful
so that they don't destroy the environment.
You're against environmental destruction,
but you're profiting from cleaning it up.
I mean it, it's that, that's a very, very
weak argument. I think the more interesting
question here is one of responsible and of
making decisions sort of for the greater good.
I've said this before, when we do a show,
we do a mix of policy analysis, things like
what should government regulation of social
media look like? And we spend a half hour
dealing with that and we do comments about,
uh, you know, stories about Trump's latest
unhinged tweets or whatever.
My approach has always been, we want to do
the most good possible. And part of doing
the most good possible is having the largest
possible audience while still being able to
do the stories we want to do. So when we do
the story about Trump's erratic tweets or
Trump's erratic rally or whatever, it is not
the deepest, most important policy analysis,
but it gets a lot of attention and it brings
people into our universe who then are in our
universe when we do the policy analysis about
government regulation of social media or comparing
different healthcare plans and uh, different
ways in which medicare for all could be implemented
or whatever. So I find it to be, you know,
the, there's this guy named Carl Benjamin,
you might know him as Sargon of a cod. He
once accused me of using clickbait youtube
titles and I brought them on a couple of years
ago and I said, it sounds like what you're
accusing me of doing is picking Youtube titles
that will make people want to watch the videos.
If the titles are accurate. It's called marketing
to choose titles that are more likely to make
someone want to watch the video, then less
likely to want to watch a video. I don't think
there's anything wrong with that. And, and
only a very sort of myopic framework would
really focus on those as the issues. Now with
regard to me interviewing Richard Spencer,
this is a longstanding debate, which is what
am I really doing by interviewing and extremist?
And the answer is, are they being responsibly
platformed or are they being given a platform
to uncritically spout propaganda, which may
actually convince people to come over to their
side or whatever the case may be. People can
disagree about this, but we've been talking
about this for years. I believe that if I
am well prepared to refute that ideas and
the ideas are prominent enough that there
is some benefit to refuting them or exposing
them or whatever the case may be, I have no
problem with responsibly platforming those
people.
And just mentioning the marketplace of ideas
or whatever, that's just a talking point.
It doesn't actually mean anything. And these,
these um, uh, talking points being repeated
ad nauseum does nothing to actually allow
us to think critically about what are the
goals of independent media, what are the sort
of guidelines that independent media should
responsibly adhere to. So if you were just
trolling, then I guess I fell for it and I
answered it like it was a serious question.
I think you raise totally valid questions.
What is responsible platforming? What is the
goal of independent media shows? What is the
line between marketing, honestly, to get people's
attention versus being deceptive? Right. And
these are all debates that are individual.
They are different. I'm willing to have all
of them. They're all legitimate. And if you're
a good faith actor wanting to discuss them,
I invite you to call into the show and we
can talk more about it.
Uh, make sure to remember that the voicemail
number is two one nine two. David P, we've
got a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Donald Trump now says that homelessness is
hurting what he calls real estate prestige.
We'll discuss that on the bonus show. We will
talk about Richard Stallman, a free software
pioneer who I have interviewed before. He
has quit his role at the Massachusetts Institute
of Technology, MIT because of some comments
he made on a list serve about Jeffrey Epstein's
a case. And we will also talk about the resurgence
of the mayor Pete versus Beto battle on gun
control. It's not a battle that will be consequential
in terms of the Democratic primary. Neither
one of them has a shot, but it's interesting.
Nonetheless, all of those stories and much
more on today's bonus show, two ways to get
instant access, become a member at join, join
pacman.com or become a patron at patrion.com/david
Pakman show. I'll speak to you on the bonus
show or otherwise, if you don't get access
to the bonus show, sadly, I will still be
right back here tomorrow. The David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.